once again his football morning in
America column was must read material
from NBC Sports Peter King back here on
the show how are you Peter
rich everything's going ok thank you how
about you are you an idiot or no no I
India is my I don't do Indy for very
long I'm a 48-hour Indy guy right all
day Friday all day Saturday go home
Sunday and I probably should do more but
I don't know I I basically want to see
the quarterbacks and want to touch base
with about 40 people and then I've mo
and then there's you know there's always
it's not just about obviously the
weekend about the on-field drills it's
really what's going on behind the scenes
in many different ways and part of the
reason why I wanted to have you on is to
suss out what you're hearing about the
competition committee that's gonna start
having a conversation about what
happened this past season and whether it
merits changing anything to avoid what
happened before despite whatever
unintended consequence might come from a
rule change or a proposal from what your
you wrote and from what I'm hearing as
well that the outrage over the NFC
Championship game has subsided and
nothing is going to be changed in the
rulebook
what are you thriver yeah i which i
think is absolutely outrageous I think
and I think that multiple members of the
competition committee basically said
well you know there's not really we'd be
opening up a can of worms in essence I
think that's what John Elway said not
long after this happened you know you
can't have pass interference a you know
reviewable foul
why can't you you know I mean and and
these other ones Judi Batista tweeted
today that that somebody you know inside
the league whatever I pick a name curry
Vincent Richmond K I'd have no idea said
that you know every time there'd be a
touchdown run in a crucial time coach
would throw the challenge flag and say I
challenged that touchdown run and there
could be an offensive hold on the plate
no no no that's not what you do if you
challenge a play that
is essentially a judgement call if you
challenge that you have to say I am
challenging X not not hey go and look at
this play and find something no that's
that's bush league and that should never
happen and and honestly rich I think it
is categorically absurd that people are
saying well ok the wrong team might have
gone to the Super Bowl because of a call
that we could have done something about
if it was reviewable the wrong team
might have gone to the Super Bowl but we
don't want to open the can of worms
what would you open the can of worms in
terms of what was discussed in the
outrage and that what people felt and
one of the most passionate communities
for football certainly in terms of
watching the game and people being into
the sport for that city to be alienated
what is more of a can of worms a a
situation that's of an unintended
consequence of a pass interference
penalty that would be reviewed
incorrectly or what we just saw in the
national in the in the NFC Championship
game but so you know it nothing about
this if the NFL does nothing about this
I'll tell you what I hope next year in a
championship game that a play happens
that's obviously miss called and it
causes another team to the another
potentially wrong team to get to the
Super Bowl it's just I mean I I just I'm
speechless
if they say there's nothing they can do
now now Rich McKay is a pragmatist
okay for those who don't know rich
president of the Atlanta Falcons
longtime chairman of the competition
committee a responsible smart guy who
wants to see the game appreciated
correctly and fairly for all the people
who criticize the competition committee
these guys devote time and they want it
they want to see this thing done fairly
mostly although I'm befuddled by those
who would say
you don't want to open that can of worms
we'll figure out how to deal with the
gay norms but I would only say this rich
mckay pragmatist I'm sure is looking at
this and saying there's no way I can get
24 votes for this well if you want to
say that then say that and put then put
the blame on the teams in the NFL that
don't want to fix an obvious gigantic
potential error looming again in another
elimination game down the road in and
and Peter you also know as does rich
knows how it works in the membership and
and the competition committee is that
sometimes it takes years to get the 24
votes you've got to start the process of
putting people on the record who's
voting for it and voting against it and
somebody votes against it the next year
suddenly votes for it in the same way
that we see the Pro Football Hall of
Fame one year you're not Hall of Fame
worthy depending on what was going on in
the landscape two years three years down
the road it just it builds it builds
until you finally get success so you've
got to do something as certainly if
there's a fan base that's out there
trying to fix a loophole that was the
worst can of worms in based on an
on-field call that I have seen in the 16
years that I've been covering the NFL
with the NFL Network so I do hope that
something is done what do you think Sean
Payton's gonna say when he walks in that
room he's on the competition committee
what do you think Peter I think he's I
think he is going to be strident and I
think he is going to say gentlemen this
is something we can fix and rich you
just made the point that that I would
make a hundred times out of 100 okay and
that is this do you remember for years
there would be maybe replay with fall
short in some form or another this would
have in fact really in the 80s and 90s
you know replay would fall short and
then they would say okay we've got 18
Rhodes blah blah blah and the people
covering the meeting would figure out
who are the teams they're voting against
it you go ask them why and and and and
it's the exact same thing here
let's get a
straw vote in the room to find out what
team say we want to fix this problem and
then find out the teams that say we
don't want to fix the problem and then
let's start ratcheting up the pressure
on them and rich you mentioned the Hall
of Fame I am absolutely fine because I
do it all the time if I have a vote for
the Hall of Fame it's it you know
because there's only 48 votes and you've
got to get 80% to get in at least to get
in I'm fine with defending my vote I
have no problem with defending my vote
pro or con but but what this is going to
allow NFL teams to do if the hide behind
anonymity which in my opinion does
nobody any good and it certainly doesn't
do the game of football any good Peter
King here on the Rich Eisen show and
other things going on beyond the the
drills and behind the scenes is usually
conversations that set up trades free
agency etc for the new league year were
where do things stand with Antonio Brown
and the Steelers and whether he can only
go to do an NFC team based on what the
Steelers wanted said or what can you
tell me on that front Peter well I don't
think rich I don't think if let's say
the New York Jets offer the Pittsburgh
Steelers far and away the best offer I
don't think that the Steelers if they
get offered a draft choice and a player
that is significantly better
compensation than then an NFC team does
I think the Steelers would be it would
be dumb to and I don't think they are
dumb organization is they're certainly
not going to trade them within the
division and but but I do believe that
they definitely want to trade them to
the NFC and not see them anymore and
there's plenty of candidates in the NFC
I listed them today
I think Carolina even though Carolina is
not in great cap shape I think Carolina
could could make it work I think David
Tepper the Pittsburgh native and former
Steeler minority owner saw with his own
eyes how great a Antonio Brown can be in
the right situation plus he really wants
to make a splash
David Tepper does to help his team
Washington has always been one of those
teams that for years wanted to win the
offseason going back to Bruce Smith and
Beyond Sanders they desperately need
good news for a fan base that is you
know has it has it had a playoff win in
a generation almost so I think those are
the two teams that would be most notable
and the ones that in my opinion would
would be the best candidates I also
think that that Washington and the Jets
potentially would be great landing spots
for Le'Veon Bell so I think former
Steelers could have some similar suitors
in the next few weeks and then obviously
nick foles
where he winds up is a monumental piece
of news that's going to break one would
assume in the next two to three weeks
what can you tell me on that front is
going on I mean it seems it seems rich
like obviously the the the Eagles want
to make sure he doesn't go to Washington
or the Giants which is probably smart
and I think there's two natural teams
Miami and Jacksonville and I just I
think that that Haskins and Murray in
this draft and the specter of the
continued things that I hear that Jon
Gruden loves Kyler Murry and perhaps
that the Arizona Cardinals could be
playing possum here and loving Kyler
Murray as much as their head coach said
last fall that he loved them so I think
this is all it's a very malleable
subject with Teddy Bridgewater Nick
Foles and perhaps down the line Derek
Carr you never know but I think this is
between in you know the draft the draft
is two months from today rich and the
only thing that is really really
interesting you know what I write about
right about the combine every year the
week before the combine and as much as I
hate to use quarterbacks as the crutch
does anybody
care where these defensive linemen go
they will in a couple of months I get it
but the real sexy part of this draft is
going to be where does Murray go where
does Haskins go and where does this
leave a couple of the free agents and
where maybe will it leave Derek Carr if
Jon Gruden's rumored love you know for
for Cuyler Murray comes to fruition okay
last one for you Peter what's the latest
on on the league with Robert Kraft what
do you think I think they've got to be
patient rich this is they've got to wait
and see what the actual evidence is in
Jupiter Florida if there is a video I
think it's going to be I don't want to
say a no-brainer but Roger Goodell I
believe is going to have to suspend
Robert Kraft for some length of time a
significant fine as I said this morning
you know Robert Kraft has always been
debts been reported on Friday something
I didn't know the fact that in 2015 he
gave $100,000 to a human trafficking
group in Boston so Manoli Robert Kraft
can mitigate the damage even if he is
suspended by becoming a somebody who
supports financially you know the the
fight against human trafficking
I would assume something like that would
be something that he would probably do
but I do think that if it's true he's
going to be taking some time off some
enforced time off but again I think we
have to wait and see what the evidence
actually says you know before presuming
that Robert Kraft is guilty Peter thanks
for the time see in Indianapolis safe
travels sounds great rich thank you you
gotta that's Peter King the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience